this game is called Datsun boxes it's
played by children in many places I
learned it in the first grade in 1946
we're going to play a game and if you
don't know the rules you'll soon learn
them as you watch this play
we have a board here it's when we end up
will have 9 boxes and when it's your
turn you can make a move I'll make the
first move like this it's your turn you
can join any two dots that are adjacent
horizontal or vertical and it's in my
turn I'll make a move here you play
anywhere you want now the goal of this
game is to make more boxes in your
opponent the rules are if your move
makes the fourth side of a box then you
get to fill that box in it becomes your
color and you you own that box so we get
scores depending on boxes
you
okay so now I make a move well I just
made the third side of box so Brady if
he if he wants to he gets the fourth
side of the box and he puts his initial
on that and he owns that box that's
Brady's box it's one point for him but
he takes an extra move now he gets a
bonus move for having made a box and he
has to move and he must move that's
right now you'd think well go ahead
he'll make a move
four and four looks like he may get I
may get four and he may get four but
let's see that done quite work so I go
here and I make this box that's one box
for all one I go here and I make another
box that's a box for all it now if I
wasn't a very bright player and I was
sort of a beginner I would continue
making two more boxes and then I'd give
him a last four but I'm smarter and I
give him a play here now I've completed
my turn without making boxes I'm done
it's his turn now and whatever he does
if he goes there it's called a double
cross that's probably his best move and
he makes two boxes in one turn yeah
but he gets only one extra move but
having made boxes he gets an extra turn
but now he has to take the extra turn
give me the last four and so I win this
game by a score of six to three so every
time I make a box I get an extra turn
and you go on like this then so the
score is six for me and three for him
did I lose because you're too good for
me or did I do something stupid you lost
because we got to a point here where
there are two long chains and a long
chain here's a chain of size four here's
another chain of size four and the
number of chains was even two and that's
why you lost this little one is a chain
of size one it's too short to matter
long chains are very important and a
long chain is one that has three or more
boxes in it the first player wants an
even number of long chains and second
player wants an odd number of long
chains
how could you control the number of long
chains well I couldn't if you'd have
played really smart from the beginning
but you had a chance even fairly late
fee to cut one of these chains into two
short chains than have been only one
long chain and you've been okay second
player strives to make an odd number of
long chains and on this board he can do
it and I'll explain how
first player strives to make an even
number wrong chains a key feature of
this board is there's only one center
square and if we look at this at the
board we can decide okay there's some
moves over here in the corners it's
called these corner moves right so we
have some corners we have some sides we
have four sides right and we have some
centers there's four centers and we have
some spokes and these moves are okay
that's all the moves there are if you
can force all long chains to go through
the center there will be only one so any
chain that not go through the center
necessarily has to be a side chain so
for example let's just look here what is
a side chain a side chain is a chain
that goes off on some side C so this in
the first game I played we got he wants
something like this now I'm threatening
to make a side chain over here see
haven't done it yet but it's it's it's
tempting so we go something like this
like this something like this something
like that something like this maybe here
maybe here and I now have a side chain
this chain is one chain there's another
chain here so there's going to be two
chains which means this is going to be a
win for the first player now the second
player could have won and the key to the
second player is winning is to stop the
side chain and the way to do this is to
play spokes these are the moves you want
I prefer to do it in a swastika pattern
if you sew these these particular moves
this set of moves is very good because
they stop all side chains
there's no way than a side chain today
so let's look at it suppose the first
player starts like this the second
players you'd think aha he's threatening
to go and make a side chain over here or
at least get started and then there'd be
very hard to me to stop it without
sacrificing some things I'm going to
break it up right away I break it I
stopped that chain from coming into
existence on that side right so he goes
over here maybe he's threatening another
one no I play another spoke I play one
of the swastika spokes I play it
perpendicular to his last move usually
right adjacent to it if I can like this
and now I can't make any side chains
over here so he's in bad shape he will
never get a second chain what about
everyone what about the top and the
bottom can these be today
countess sidechains only if he can make
a chain but how's it going to make a
chain if he tries watch he tries he
tries us see but I stopped that to
second player goes here so now that we
have two little chains they don't matter
it's only the big chains account and so
there isn't now maybe he succeeds in
being no chains which would be good for
the second player in the end game but
the only way he can make no chains is
the sacrifice he might do that he might
give away two boxes right now but if
that's the case there's no chains the
little stuff will all be divided up
evenly and I'll win on the sacrifice on
a game that is four dots by four dots or
three boxes by three boxes yeah play
second play the spokes and you will do
play they all in a spokes isn't a
swastika you don't let him get Center in
a site adjacent to each other because if
he does that that's that's a threat to
run a chain through here and the only
way you're gonna be able to stop it as a
sacrifice a box don't don't give away
any sacrifice until you have to stop the
side chains right away by playing the
alternate spokes and play them adjacent
whenever he makes the center or side he
goes and moves in a corner that's no
problem you just let that move be now if
he plays a spoke fine that's the way
that we like the more spokes the better
should we play a game and see if I can
beat you no okay oh my god so
immediately the danger to me here is you
pay up there that's for sure so I want
to make a spoke yes right yes great idea
okay now again that's good for me but
from what you told me that's my danger
now yes so I want to make another spoke
yes oh I have not hope anymore this
early in the game you're thinking I now
have no hope true
now again this is my this is my danger
well first of all there's a box and if
you don't take that box I will now
there's threats on both sides does that
scare you why well because even number
of chains gives you the game yeah unless
they're all small so you can stop there
from being - just there to threats now
you stop one the other is only going to
be one so I play here that's fine these
have both become small chains that's
right and now we're back to only one big
chain and that's good for me or maybe
zero I mean I can make zero change but
since you're already one point ahead
that's right that's right
you get both of those right and you give
me to give you and I give you to you you
ends normally and actually you got six
two three because I sort of I played
elwyn berlekamp and dots and boxes only
after you talk oh I tell you the
proudest thing a teacher ever does is
when he gets students who are better
than him this video was filmed at MSR
eye in Berkeley California but perhaps
fittingly for a video about dots and
boxes it's also been sponsored by
Squarespace if you're looking to set up
a website or a blog or an online store I
really recommend Squarespace in fact I
recently got fed up with my own blog and
I've started using Squarespace and I
wish I'd done it a long time ago it's
really enjoyable to use they've got
these great startup templates you can
start building with but then customize
them as little or as much as you'd like
really usable really good customer
service and importantly the websites you
make on Squarespace automatically look
really good well on big grown-up
computers but also on your handheld
devices your mobile phones now you can
just go to the site have a look you can
even play around and build your own site
no credit card details or anything like
that just see what you think and then if
you do like it and I think you probably
will you can get 10% off by using the
code numberphile it also lets the people
at Squarespace know that you came from
here in fact you can just go to the
website squarespace.com slash
numberphile find out the rest from there
as I said I use them myself I'm a really
happy customer and you might be too but
regardless thank you to Squarespace for
sponsoring this video about
appropriately dots and boxes